nous voulons déterminer s'il s'agit
d'une faiblesse au niveau de la sécurité
ou pas nous allons certainement la
conduite un seul homme existe ailleurs
dans le monde
ce n'est pas nécessairement dangereuse
cela dépend du contexte et le rose very
soon after des axes la question a surgi
immédiatement après l'accident et nous
l'examinerons en profondeur
comment cette décision at elle été prise
et s'agissait-il d'un risque akrad le
prochain accident grave ne surviendra
pas sur une voie secondaire en pleine
nuit avec une locomotive sans
surveillance nous avons appris au fil de
nos enquêtes que les accidents se
reproduisent mais que leurs coûts sont
différentes à jack bonne cause
pour éviter une tragédie comme celle de
l'accm identique
il faut identifier les risques et les
réduire le gap des risques sociaux ni
trahi tout sauf l'industrie doit faire
un pas de plus je suis persuadé qu'il
faut instaurer un meilleur système de
gestion de la sécurité
l'industrie possède beaucoup de données
sur les risques qu'ils permettent
d'anticiper les accidents il ne s'agit
pas de revenir sur les causes de la
dernière tragédie mais de comprendre où
le prochain déraillement va survenir et
menus le prévenir du helmand
vous êtes au milieu d'une ville dont le
coeur a été détruit c'est bouleversant
in motion
je crois que notre équipe souhaite
ardemment aller au fond des choses pour
les gens de l'accm identique depuis bob
lac-mégantic socan we expect you go and
find exact oui oui je voulais sur wii